foreign
ature an editorial if you will show this
Zachary missing data means we'll
probably never know how many people died
of covid
huge discrepancies and estimates of
excess mortality revealed not just how
difficult the calculations are but how
far the world has to go in recording how
people die now
excess mortality
like estimates Hospitality specifically
don't require that you know how people
died that's the point right that is that
is the point also this editorial I was
going to walk through how stupid it is
but I'm not currently so again we've
already had
science anointing fouchy as the
next coming of Jesus Christ and now we
have in the same week nature the other
preeminent science journal in the world
with this Pap and they are referring to
an article that they published this week
out of
um
called The Who estimates of excess
mortality associated with the covid-19
pandemic and in this article we have
figure one which has Global access and
reported covid-19 deaths and death rates
per 100 000 population
now this is cumulative
but
um check out how covid was killing
people and then
um the rate increased
in 2021
and then this is not cumulative this is
just
um reported covid-19 death rate per 100
000. this is figure 1B of the same
article that just came out the death
rate per 100 000 and covid was killing
people Northern summer of 2020 it dipped
slightly and then it boy did it start
killing people again except it's not
that covid was killing people right it's
that we have excess mortality right so
it's the red line so I'm reading that
like someone I was saying that as if
someone might look at this go like oh my
God look at all the coma does like no we
have
deaths attributed to covert with the red
line and we have excess mortality with
the purple line here and the purple line
has some has some spikes
um honestly right around
the rollout of the vaccine and then
right around when suddenly everyone had
access to the vaccine and you can't say
from this that it was coveted or it was
the vaccine or it was hepatitis or it
was cancer it was heart disease it was
anything but what you can do is you can
say
let's look at data on excess mortality
which is death counts that's all it
takes death counts compare it to
previous death counts and then
separately let's look at all of the
things that happen in the world to which
particular spikes might be attributed so
this is consistent the whose report
polish in nature this week is consistent
with Ben's work from earlier
but somehow the nature news report the
editorial version of nature instead
reports this headline missing data mean
we'll probably never know how many
people died of coven
that's actually not the message of the
work they're reporting on yeah well it's
funny it's like I mean we know that
people in many places worst of all
science but many places people report
you know they read the title of a paper
that leans in some Direction they want
or they read the title in the abstract
and they don't delve any further than
this they cite it because they're
they've become advocates for some
position and the thing seems to push in
that direction so it doesn't almost
matter what it says right and so in some
sense this phony world that they've
created the phony Tony world is
um
basically hungry for stuff that you can
point to for your laugh line if you're
Stephen Colbert or whatever but it's
just stuff it doesn't matter that
there's anything underneath it it can
just be an assertion that comes from a
place like Yale right and it's good
enough and so that you know whoa boy
that sounds like a sophisticated
analysis that the there's missing data
that's going to prevent us from ever
knowing right they want to seed the idea
oh we're never going to know why are we
never gonna know because we're never
going to do the right study and why are
we never going to do the right study
because a lot of people can't afford for
us to do the right study it's not hard
the data isn't missing yes it will be
noisy but you know do you know what
those giant buildings full of people who
do science are about
knowing how to study questions like this
and and frankly once once you've paired
it all away and you've you've you know
you've realized that oh my God uh the
PCR tests aren't the right things to be
testing for this and died with versus
died of covet is really messy and we're
never going to fully untangle that
the measure of excess mortality doesn't
require any of that it doesn't require
that we untangle any of that doesn't
require that it's the beauty of it any
of it it is so beautiful it is so simple
and yes if there's something else that
happened in late 2019 early 2020 or in
late 2020 early 2021 through now that we
are yet unaware of we will potentially
mistake one one pattern for the other
but excess mortality simply looks at how
many people died and historically at the
same time of year how many people died
and how many more are there yeah well
and you know even even if there were
something that magically showed up at
that same moment right we have various
different countries in which we had
different patterns and so you can unpack
that as well there's nothing here that
is beyond study this this is not harder
than your average question in fact this
is so much easier than we are making it
out to be and unfortunately we're now I
think the new game is
um that they've reversed the burden of
proof which is one of their favorites
yeah right that that's what happened uh
with these people who are extremely high
quality scientists on desantis's panel
the reason that we disagree is that
they've had the burden of proof reversed
on them and so they're trying to be very
careful because they've spent careers
being careful but the problem is careful
has been flipped on its head you know so
um
there's no reason yeah I will point out
it's not the only thing that went
missing according to this uh report do
you notice that Pfizer's document its
agreement with Israel went missing I
don't what what are we talking about the
the report that you just put up saying
that the uh
um the uh data has is missing and that
it will prevent us from knowing who
whether or not we've had a increase in
oh some something else is kind of
messing something else it is the
agreement between Pfizer and the state
of Israel has apparently also gone
missing it's just gone they don't know
yeah
um apparently they had someone in over
the weekend to clean up and so anyway
it's possible she placed it somewhere
but that'll happen yeah
it does happen yeah right I mean sure
um
but yeah I mean Israel should really get
its act together it's very disorganized
and not you know not able to get things
done in general right right
no that's like every other nation state
after I mean let's you know let's let's
Steel Man their argument I mean Israel
you know it's a small country but it's
still a big place there are a lot of
places they could have you know so
they're some presumably they haven't
checked absolutely right they're gonna
have to do a systematic check of all of
the Cubbies and other small places in
Israel that this document could be
hiding um right and oh and that's before
they even get to the computers I was
just going to say not not to say
anything about
um the virtual Universe right that yeah
the number of so many Cubbies yeah
Israel inside their computers there's
got to be I mean hundreds of places that
document could hide
maybe even order some attitude more than
that
who knows
[Music]